und jetzt die bundeskanzlerin sehr
geehrter sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
schöne an freiheitlichen debatten ist
dass jeder über das spricht was er für
das land für wichtig hält
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieses hier unsere vierte
haushaltsdebatte in diesem jahr
und das hat natürlich damit zu tun dass
wir lange keinen hochzeit für 2018
hatten und dass wir jetzt zeitgerechten
haushalt für 2009 10 beschließen in
einem umfeld bei dem wir nach wie vor
wirtschaftswachstum haben im neunten
jahr in folge
wir haben über 45 millionen
erwerbstätige wir haben einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt wir haben im
vergangenen jahr zum ersten mal das von
uns lange erarbeitete ziel von drei
prozent ausgaben für forschung und
entwicklung erreicht unsere
investitionsquote kann sich sehen lassen
und unser schuldenstand wird bald wieder
die maastricht kriterien erfüllt und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich will
hier nur im kurzformat sagen was diese
bundesregierung der großen koalition
bereits auf den weg gebracht haben die
vielen einzel etats die hier debattiert
werden stellen dass sie ausführlicher da
wir haben familien entlastet wir haben
die kalte progression bekämpft wir haben
mittel für sozialen wohnungsbau
ausgereicht wir haben das baukindergeld
eingeführt wir haben ein wohnungs gipfel
durchgeführt wir uns mit den eigentlich
wichtigen fragen neben dem geld
beschäftigen nämlich der verfügbarkeit
von bauland und der beschleunigung von
bauer
wir haben im bereich der familien
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf
durch das durch die brücken teilzeit
durch das gute kita gesetz wichtige
weichen gestellt und
ich will auch hier nur ganz kurz noch
einmal darauf hinweisen dass die
bundesfrauenministerin gestern noch ein
phänomen hingewiesen hat was uns alle um
treiben muss nämlich gewalt gegen frauen
in unserem land wird es richtig dass wir
hier auch im bundeshaushalt einen akzent
setzen und dagegen etwas zu tun und auch
länder und kommunen
[Musik]
wir haben die allianz für pflege wir
haben das pflege verstärkung gesetz auf
den weg gebracht wir haben wesentliche
weichenstellungen im rentensystem
getroffen festhaltung der rentenniveaus
bis 2025 verbesserung der
erwerbsunfähigkeitsrente verbesserung
der mütter rente wir haben in
weiterbildungsbereich im blick auf die
digitalisierung weichen gestellt wir
haben die exzellenzinitiative für
forschung auf den weg gebracht sondern
ausschreiben um für erneuerbare energien
die sammelklage möglichkeit gerade im
blick auf vw wir haben im blick auf die
diese fragen des bundes
immissionsschutzgesetz verändert und
mehr rechtsklarheit zu bekommen und wir
haben eine vielzahl von gesetzen
verabschiedet im zusammenhang mit der
steuerung ordnung von fülle von
flüchtlingen und von migration
wir haben 2 wir haben drei wichtige
kommissionen auf den weg gebracht von
denen eine die kommission zum
strukturwandel in den braunkohle
gebieten jetzt in die entscheidende
phase kommt und deshalb werde ich noch
einmal deutlich machen dass es uns hier
darum geht klimawandel auf der einen
seite und zukunft für menschen in einen
einklang zu bringen es geht nicht darum
als erstes irgendwelche ausstiegsdaten
zu beschließen soll es geht darum
menschen hoffnung zu geben zukunft zu
geben strukturwandel wirklich
vorzubereiten um ihnen dann die
sicherheit zu geben zu sagen ja auch wir
werden unseren beitrag für den
klimawandel leisten
wir werden die kommission gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse in deutschland haben
die uns besonders wichtig ist und die
renten kommission und wir werden noch
vor weihnachten einfach kräfte
einwanderungsgesetz beschließen also
alles dinge die von größter wichtigkeit
sind aber ich möchte mich heute auf zwei
punkte konzentrieren
vielleicht die aber auf jeden fall sehr
große herausforderungen im zusammenhang
mit dem was unsere zukunft anbelangt das
erste ist das was technologie getrieben
ist das ist die digitalisierung diese
digitalisierung wird unser leben in
allen bereichen tiefgreifend und
qualitativ verändert
wir haben in der vergangenen woche eine
zweitägige klausurtagung gemacht werden
die struktur der bundesregierung
entspricht in dieser legislaturperiode
den aufgaben und den notwendigkeiten und
ich bin sehr froh dass ich auch im
parlament entsprechende kommissionen
finden die sich mit dem digitalen wandel
noch einmal beschäftigen
die zeit drängt wir sind stehen in einen
wahnsinnigen globalen wettbewerb und wir
stehen in der herausforderung diesen
wettbewerb so zu gestalten dass er auch
im siebzigsten jahr der sozialen
marktwirtschaft uns die chance gibt das
so zu gestalten dass der mensch im
mittelpunkt steht und nicht die technik
den menschen beherrscht das ist die
große aufgabe und die große überschrift
über der das alles stadt sind meine
damen und herren da geht es natürlich
als erstes mal und das so viel
diskutiert um die infrastruktur die es
nach wie vor noch unzureichend in
unserem land aber ich glaub wir sind
jetzt auf einem guten weg wir haben
ausführlich auch im parlament diskutiert
die ausschreibungen für die neueste
technologie die 5g frequenzen und deren
versteigerung wir stehen wir natürlich
in einem spannungsfeld von politischen
vorgaben und investitionsmöglichkeiten
derer die investieren wollen
aber genauso wichtig ist natürlich dass
wir eine versorgung der haushalte
mit ausreichendem 4g standard hierzu hat
der bundes in frack struktur minister an
die steuer die richtigen
förderbedingungen jetzt noch einmal
weiterentwickelt damit dass
unbürokratischer gehen kann
wir werden ende 2009 10 98 prozent der
haushalte angeschlossen haben und ende
2021 99 prozent der haushalte aber wie
wir alle wissen und täglich erleben
reicht uns das natürlich nicht aus denn
zu hause angebot von breitem internet zu
haben ist gut und richtig wir machen
jetzt auch sonder ausschreibungen für
krankenhäuser gewerbegebiete schulen
auch richtig aber wir wollen natürlich
flächendeckendes internet und genau
daran wird gearbeitet und insbesondere
im zusammenhang mit der kommission
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse werden
wir das was gerade auch für die
ländlichen regionen was für die
landwirtschaftsministerium wichtig ist
dann in den blick nehmen und dazu
lösungen finden paar bundeskanzler der
abgeordnete fischer fdp möchte gern eine
zwischenfrage stellen ein möchtegern
zusammenhängt sprechen
das generation ihre räte das gilt
generell reinreden neben der
infrastruktur geht es jetzt darum dass
der staat auch reagiert auf die digitale
herausforderung deshalb werden wir jetzt
auch online zugangs gesetz was wir ja
bereits in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode entschieden haben mit
leben erfüllen und das bürgerportal auch
realität werden lassen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist eine
wichtige ich würde sagen eine zukunft
entscheidende aufgabe die mehr als
vieles andere eine enge zusammenarbeit
von bund ländern und kommunen erfordert
wir sind ein föderales land bei uns geht
es nicht ich habe gestern den dänischen
kollegen getroffen
dass rasmussen der mir erklärt hat dass
sie das alles vor jahren schon mit ihren
kommunen gemacht haben wir als föderales
gebilde tun uns da sehr schwer und das
wichtigste was wir jetzt erstmal mit den
ländern erreichen müssen ist ein zepter
für den bürger akzeptabler zugang zu
diesem portal der nicht so kompliziert
ist dass keiner das nutzt und dann geht
es darum dass wir über 500 funktionen
haben die bürgerinnen und bürger mit
ihrem start-up arbeiten und aldi müssen
jetzt digitalisiert werden
und ich spreche also ausführlich darüber
weil wir zwei dinge zu beachten sind
das erst oder eine wesentliche sache zu
beachten ist und zwar dass wir vom
bürger her denken und nicht unsere
projekte so durchsetzen wie wir das
gewohnt sind
wir sind im normalen schauen sie wir
sind im normalen klassischen denken
gewohnt ein projekt zu planen
das gesamte projekt dann schrittweise
umzusetzen während im digitalen
zeitalter eine völlig andere art der
herangehensweise da ist und schritt für
schritt dem die anwendungen eingeführt
werden müssen und dieses richtige denken
beim umsetzen des bürgerparks wird sehr
wichtig sein wir werden erste funktionen
nämlich die des bundes das sind über 100
sehr schnell einführen und wir werden
damit den ländern die anderen 400
funktionen auch durchsetzen so dass wir
dann ende 2022 wirklich den vollkommen
und kompletten zugang von fahrzeug
anmeldung über elterngeld beantragen
steuererklärung gesundheitsakten und
vielen vielen anderen dingen digital
schaffen
das ist notwendig das ist kein sozusagen
nerd projekt wie man vielleicht sagen
könnte sondern wenn die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht diesen zugang bekommen
werden wir im digitalen zeitalter nicht
bestehen und deshalb muss der staat
vorbild
drittens infrastruktur digitaler stadt
drittens die strategie für die
künstliche intelligenz voraussetzung
dafür dass wir industrie 4.0 dann auch
wirklich erfolgreich in deutschland
realisieren kann
wir werden hier zwölf zentren bilden die
sich vernetzen wir werden 100 neue
professuren einführen wir werden mit
frankreich eng kooperieren und wir
werden unsere agenturen für disruptive
innovationen ganz stark auf diese dinge
ausrichten ich glaube dass es hier
möglichkeiten gibt aufzuholen
möglichkeiten gibt den anschluss zu
finden wir sind in einzelnen punkten
auch spitze aber wir sind nicht überall
weltklasse und unser anspruch muss sein
wir wollen wieder überall weltklasse
werden das gilt für deutschland und das
gilt für europa meinen dank und wir
haben uns im blick auf die frage wie die
die ganze sache den menschen mit der
frage beschäftigt wie ist das mit der
ethik der daten wir haben heute zwei
modelle die amerikaner wo die daten der
bürgerinnen und bürger sehr stark im
privaten sektor verankert sind und im
privaten sektor gehören
wir haben china wo der staat zugriff auf
alle daten hat das ist nicht das modell
der sozialen marktwirtschaft und deshalb
müssen wir eines finden bei der der
einzelne mensch im mittelpunkt steht und
der staat leitplanken gesetzt und das
genau ist die aufgabe der daten
ethikkommission meine damen und herren
die uns im nächsten jahr ihre auch ihre
arbeiten vorstellen wird und ihre
ergebnisse
das ist
im kurz umriss die große digitale
herausforderung von der wir natürlich
der wirtschaft zur seite stehen
unterstützen können
aber wo natürlich auch die gesamte
wirtschaft sich verändern wird industrie
4.0 bedeutet nicht nur veränderung im
produzieren industrie 4.0 bedeutet
erhebliche veränderungen in der arbeit
und auch gerade bei der frage der
weiterbildung diese frage stellt sich im
übrigen auch für die beamtinnen und
beamten und angestellten des bundes bei
der frage der weiterbildung werden wir
bereits schlecht unterstützen wir haben
bereits jetzt ein gesetz auf den weg
gebracht nachdem es möglich ist dass
dann die unternehmen die im zusammenhang
mit der digitalisierung fortbildung und
qualifizierung brauchen erhebliche
zuschüsse je kleiner je größer der
prozentsatz der zuschüsse für diese neue
aufgabe der weiterbildung bekommen
meine damen und herren die zweite
herausragen die ist für uns politisch
glaube ich mindestens so relevant aber
eigentlich noch relevant und da geht es
um die frage wie unsere
gesellschaftlichen vorstellungen unsere
deutschen vorstellungen für die zukunft
der globalen welt aussehen und ich
glaube die vergangenen tage haben uns
noch einmal in erinnerung gerufen
in welchem historischen kontext wir
stehen
wir stehen ja alle immer in unserer zeit
und am freitag der vergangenen woche vor
zwölf tagen war hier die gedenkstunde
zur ausrufung der republik vor 100
jahren durch philipp scheidemann
der bundespräsident hat anlässlich
dieses jahrestages ein rede gehalten aus
der ich mir erlaube zu zitieren
wir müssen wieder kämpfen für den
zusammenhalt in europa und wir müssen
streiten für eine internationale ordnung
die angefochten wird selbst von unseren
partnern
denn dieser europäischen einigung und
dieser internationalen ordnung haben wir
es zu verdanken
dass wir deutsche heute wieder ein volk
sind das wirtschaftlich und politisch zu
kräften gekommen ist das in seiner
großen mehrheit weltoffen ist und
europäisch leben will das von vielen in
der welt geachtet ja sogar geschätzt
wird
zitat ende und alle tag später war ich
von dem französischen präsidenten im
handel markt eingeladen an der
gedenkstätte in companion des
hundertsten jahrestag der unterzeichnung
des waffenstillstandes zwischen
deutschland und frankreich zu gedenken
und das war besiegelt noch kein
bundeskanzler war an diesem platz
gewesen und bis zuletzt bis zum 10
november 2008 10 war dort ein
gedenkstein auf dieser gedenkplatte
standen worte vom verbrecherische stolz
des deutschen reiches und diese
gedenkplakette ist jetzt ersetzt worden
und aus dem verbrecherischen stolz wurde
die deutsch französische freundschaft
und symbolische
dort kann man vielleicht das was ich da
getan hat in den letzten jahrzehnten
nicht beschreiben und als vor vier tagen
emanuel makro anlässlich des
volkstrauertages hier im deutschen
bundestag seine rede gesagt gehalten hat
und die worte gefunden hat wenn sie die
worte aus frankreich nicht verstehen
denken sie daran dass frankreich sie
liebt da war das mehr als berührend es
ist aber vor allen dingen für uns eine
verpflichtung
und ich sage das in bezug darauf dass
uns doch in diesen tagen immer und immer
wieder die bohrende frage lautet was
haben wir aus der geschichte gelernt und
haben wir aus der geschichte gemacht und
ich glaube dass diese frage nicht nur
wegen hunderter jahrestage interessant
ist sondern ich glaube dass diese frage
so wichtig ist weil wir immer weniger
zeit zeugen gerade auch des
schrecklichen und von deutschland
verursachten zweiten weltkriegs unter
uns haben werden und weil wir alleine
sein werden
die generationen die nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg geboren sind und weil wir
zeigen müssen ob wir etwas gelernt haben
und warum warum war es möglich dass
deutschland diesen zweiten weltkrieg
entfacht hat mit dazu beigetragen ohne
die deutsche schuld zu relativieren
haben zwei dinge
der waffenstillstand war keine
aussöhnung und es ist nicht gelungen das
was sich der amerikanische präsident
wilson vorgestellt hatte eine
internationale multilaterale ordnung zu
schaffen
in form eines funktionierenden
völkerbundes und die lehren aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg waren dann
glücklicherweise die eine multilaterale
ordnung zu schaffen und dafür steht die
gründung der vereinten nationen
und diese vereinten nationen sind die
lehre aus der geschichte des zweiten
weltkriegs nie wieder gegeneinander zu
arbeiten sondern wo immer möglich zu
versuchen gemeinsam als weltgemeinschaft
die dinge zu klären
und als der kalte krieg noch nicht alles
überschattet hatte gelang es dann sogar
1948 noch auch dies ein jahrestag die
charta der menschenrechte bei den
vereinten nationen zu verabschieden
sie würde alle menschen sind frei und
gleich an würde und rechten geboren so
heißt es dort sehr ähnlich zum artikel 1
unseres grundgesetzes die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar
sie zu achten und zu schützen ist
verpflichtung aller staatlichen gewalt
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen den
allermeisten muss man das hier nicht
sagen aber diese vereinten nationen sind
demokratisch legitimiert sie sind eine
entscheidung der weltgemeinschaft und
jeder der beigetreten ist treten ist
dort haben wo immer existent parlamenten
ratifiziert dass man mitglied dieser
vereinten nationen sein will und das ist
die grundlage von aus plastik und zug um
zug hat sich eigentlich schlecht von
organisationen um diese und in dieser in
diesen vereinten nationen herausgebildet
die für uns heute so wichtig sind die
vier millionen flüchtlinge wichtig sind
wie zum beispiel der un hcr und sehr
interessant ist die herausbildung einer
organisation die erst seit 2016 unter
dem dach der vereinten nationen agiert
nämlich der internationalen organisation
für migration das war nämlich ein
intergouvernemental es komitee für die
bewegung wie es damals hieß der
migranten aus europa nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg
damals sind elf millionen menschen
migranten wie man damals schon sagte in
europa umher geirrt und diese
organisation hat versucht ihnen wieder
einer
dazu gehen sie hat sich dann später aber
in ungarn aufstand 1956 bewährt sie hat
geholfen bei der tschechoslowakei 1968
sie hat im kosovo überhäufen geholfen
uns im kino und seit 2016 erst ist sie
unter der ägide der vereinten nationen
es war also eine europäische
organisation die sich mit dem schrecken
des europäischen kriege beschäftigt hat
bevor sie überhaupt internationalisiert
deshalb liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist die debatte über das was wir jetzt
fügen über den globalen pakt für
migration für eine geordnete legale
migration ja in einer welt in der wir
noch 222 gewaltsam ausgetragenen
konflikte haut in einer welt bei der von
diesen konflikt mehr als eine milliarde
kinder betroffen
in einer welt wir 68 5 millionen
flüchtlinge haben 52 prozent davon
kinder spielen diese organisationen
natürlich eine zentrale rolle
und als wir im jahre 2015 gemerkt haben
dass wir uns nicht abkoppeln können von
dem leid von menschen in der umgebung
europas als wir nicht ausreichend
bezahlt hatten in die flüchtlingslager
vom libanon und von jordanien ich habe
das oft hierher
da haben wir gespürt wie wichtig ist es
flucht aber auch migration im
zusammenhang des internationalen kontext
es zu lösen und nicht zu glauben
irgendein land könnte das alleine
wenn heute der eindruck erweckt werden
als wäre all das was in diesem pakt für
migration jetzt auftaucht irgend etwas
über das wir nie gesprochen hätten
dann ist doch dass gegen das er ist doch
dass das gegenteil von richtig seit der
frage der flüchtlinge die der vielen
flüchtlinge die zu uns kamen haben wir
uns gefragt wie können wir dieses
problem lösen und haben dann nicht immer
zur freude aller das war meine erste eu
türkei abkommen verabschiedet dieses eu
türkei ag hat zum ersten mal zu einer
geregelten frage der migration geführt
hat flüchtlingen das leben gerettet weil
sie sich nicht mehr in die hände von
schleppern und schleusern begeben musste
und danach haben wir eine zusammenarbeit
mit afrika aufgebaut
die emotionen sofia die libysche
küstenwache die unsere kooperation mit
niger als transitland wo die
internationale organisation für
migration uns hilft liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich war da ich war in den
niger ich habe mir das angeguckt wie
menschen die aus libyen zurückkehren
weil sie unmenschlich behandelt wurden
bei der em ein aufenthalt finden und von
dort dann wieder zurück in ihre
heimatländer geleitet werden das genau
ist die frage wie man menschlich mit
league mit illegaler migration umgeht
und genau das ist ein ansatzpunkt in
diesem tag menschen verpflichten
schon vertreten
und wir haben diesen verhandlungen
obwohl wir wissen dass wir es nur
international messen können wert darauf
gelegt zu sagen die souveränität unseres
eigenen landes unsere gesetzgebung wird
nicht berührt aber wir wollen
vernünftige bedingungen wir wollen
vernünftige bedingungen überall auf der
welt weil ansonsten natürlich die
menschen sagen du hast nur wenige länder
in die eu gehen kannst und es versuchen
und ihr eigenes leben aufs spiel setzen
und deshalb ist es in unserem nationalen
interesse um es ganz klar zu sagen dass
die bedingungen auf der welt für flucht
auf der einen seite und migration auf
der anderen seite arbeitsmigration sich
verbessern wir wollen
wir wollen wenn in katar stadien gebaut
werden dass dort noch ein deutsches
anliegen ein anliegen der deutschen
gewerkschaften dass die dort arbeitenden
bauarbeiter vernünftig behandelt werden
dass sie nicht ausgebeutet werden dass
ich nicht kinderarbeit gibt und was
sonst noch alles auf der welt ist von
dem wir glücklicherweise überhaupt keine
ahnung wer aber wenn wir uns dafür
einsetzen dass es woanders auf der welt
besser wird dann kann es doch nicht sein
dass wir hinterher sagen dann wollen wir
aber nicht mehr mitmachen wenn wir nicht
ganz sicher sind dass auch die letzte
feier geklärt ist dieser pakt für
migration
diese pakt für migration genauso wie der
pakt für flüchtlinge ist die riecht der
richtige antwort versucht wir stehen ja
am anfang
globale probleme auch international und
miteinander zu lösen
und deshalb war es richtig dass sich die
un vollversammlung 2016 auf den weg
gemacht hat diese 2 packte zu verhandeln
und deshalb ist es richtig jetzt auch
den pakt für migration dem zuzustimmen
es wird übrigens nichts unterzeichnet
nichts unterschrieben ist nicht
rechtlich bin um das auch noch alles
nochmal gesagt haben uns meine damen und
herren das soll aber
und das soll aber doch gar keine ausrede
sein
wir haben recht ich binde vorschriften
für den umgang mit menschen wir haben
eine ausgefeilte verfassungsrecht
sprechen
bei uns bekommen die menschen eine
grundlegende sicherung bei uns bekommen
sie einen zugang zum gesundheitssystem
alles selbstverständlich und wir wollen
natürlich dass dies in vielen ländern
der welt der fall ist als das heute der
ist liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
auch die europäische union ist denn sie
wollen ein multilaterales projekt und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
freizügigkeit innerhalb der europäischen
union zur aufnahme von arbeit ist eine
der form von legale migration die sie
gerade dieser pakt für migration
beschreibt und diese freizügigkeit hat
uns wohlstand gebracht
nicht nur deutschland sondern auch
anderen ländern und diese freizügigkeit
ist eine ehrung
auf der europäischen union und schauen
sie das schöne an der heutigen zeit ist
dass es wieder richtige gegensätze geht
und dass man einfach sagen muss da gibt
es auch keine kompromisse entweder man
gehört zu denen die glauben sie können
alles alleine lösen und müssen nur an
sich denken das ist nationalismus in
reinster form das ist kein patriotismus
und patriotismus ist wenn man in solchen
interesse aus anderen beteiligten
situation akzeptiert
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
europa ist ein multilaterales projekt
und diese europäische union gilt es zu
stärken
das tun wir denn in nahezu sechs monaten
werden wir in eine europawahl ziehen
und deshalb wollen wir die deshalb
wollen wir die wirtschafts und
währungsunion wetterfester machen da
stehen jetzt die zeichen günstig um mal
was anderes zu sagen dass stehen jetzt
die zeichen günstig wenn wir die banken
union machen den esm weiterentwickeln zu
einem wechsel und natürlich auch die
risiken reduzieren denn es gibt jetzt
eine zusammenarbeit zwischen mars und
alle und insofern werden die bedenken
von hinten etwas geringer werden das
freut uns und hilft uns in unseren
verhandlungen sehr viel
ansonsten haben wir uns auf einen euro
billiger einig das haben sie vernommen
ich möchte aber zu einem anderen thema
im blick auf europa sprechen
und das ist die frage des austritts
großbritanniens wir sind nach wie vor
traurig darüber dass großbritannien die
europäische union verlässt aber wir
akzeptieren und respektieren das
natürlich das haben wir hier viel gesagt
ich möchte nicht mehr sterben je danken
und seinem team die eine unendlich
langen verhandlungen jetzt des austritts
abkommen mit großbritannien finalisieren
kunden
wir haben noch einen vorbehalt spaniens
wozu ich nicht genau sagen kann wie wir
dieses thema lösen denn ich hoffe es
wird gelöst bis sonntag und es wird
jetzt in diesen tagen noch an der
erklärung zum zukünftigen verhältnis
zwischen großbritannien und der eu
gearbeitet
beide dokumente müssen bis sonntag
fertig sein damit wir sonntag dann die
entsprechende unterzeichnung des
austritts abkommens und die akzeptanz
des abt des erklärung zur zukünftigen
verhältnis dann auch verabschieden will
wir wissen wie schwierig auch die
diskussion in großbritannien ist ich
kann aber für die bundesregierung sagen
wir stimmen diesem austritt vertrag
zuerst hart erarbeitet und er ist
deshalb so kompliziert weil ein austritt
aus der europäischen union sowieso schon
kompliziert ist
aber durch das thema nordirland und
republik irland die einen sozusagen
grenzfreien das miteinander haben wollen
durch das good friday agreement entsteht
eine sehr sehr schwierig zu lösende
konstellation wir haben darauf wert
gelegt und ich glaube das ist richtig
dass großbritannien nicht einseitig
entscheiden kann wann es den zustand der
zollunion beendet sondern dass
großbritannien mit der eu gemeinsam
diesem zeitpunkt definieren muss und
danach dann das zukünftige verhältnis in
kraft tritt und natürlich ist es bei
einem solchen vertrag immer so dass man
auch darauf setzen muss dass das gut
funktioniert und ich glaube das kann man
weil wir wollen hier und das ist in
unserem elementarem interesse eine gute
beziehung zu großbritannien auch in der
zukunft im bereich der verteidigungs
zusammenarbeit im bereich der
sicherheitszusammenarbeit aber auch im
bereich vieler internationaler
konferenzen wollen wir gute freunde und
partner bleiben und dafür werde ich
jedenfalls alles einsetzen und die ganze
bundesregierung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen so müssen
wir sagen
eine intensive und sehr vielleicht
manchmal auch sehr nervöse zeit im
rückblick zu 30 jahren zuvor muss man
sagen die welt des kalten krieges war
schrecklich in vielen facetten aber sie
war übersichtlich in den letzten 30
jahren hat sich ein multilaterale
weltordnung herausgebildet mit
verschiedenen zentren bei denen nicht
klar ist wie sie miteinander agieren
wollen in zukunft und in einer solchen
situation kommt es auf jedes einzelne
land an und wir sind hier der deutsche
bundestag
und ich stehe vor ihm als kanzlerin der
bundesregierung
und wir haben die aufgabe dazu
beizutragen dass diese welt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts davon
ausgeht dass jeder eine chance für seine
entwicklung hat dass wir frieden haben
und dass wir nicht zuerst an uns selbst
denken sondern verstehen dass deutsches
interesse heißt immer auch die anderen
mitzudenken das ist der erfolg
das ist ja fast einer milliarde welt
herzlichen dank